ça fait un moment qu'on n'a pas fait de
vidéo tous les trois la dernière n'était
pas très réussis tu te fous regardez
déjà quand on tourne en sortir je prends
la parole c'est quoi les gars mais quand
je tourne avec toi mais alors déjà je
suis toujours ici
ouais mais alors quand je suis avec 1000
les travaux théoriques comme l'a révélé
youtuber de france est-ce que je peux
parler continuant refaire sa re pourquoi
on est dans une salle comme ça quelle
quelle connerie ça alors j'ai plein de
choses à dire la première il ya une
réverbération dantesque dans une salle
on n'y peut rien c'est vite je vous
rappelle que j'en avoir mené au bureau
tout n'est pas encore aménagé et là on
remet ça nous arrange parce qu'en plus
de cette rivière de dantesques il y a
dix travaux il n'y a pas de clim non aux
conditions de tournage la note c zéro
surtout lui qui fait le plus de bruit
avec sa tête sur la table les vidéos
qu'on a fait ensemble sur la chaîne ont
marqué les gens les objets japonais
besoin d'eux trois épisodes où le studio
a failli prendre feu épisode on s'est
rendu compte que raf était profondément
attaché au baseball
ensuite il mais cet épisode sortira vous
même c'est tout a foiré
tout était de ma soirée drôle
aujourd'hui quatre activités différentes
dont une qui justifient toute la bâche
plastique dont qui est en train de
tomber
la première les gars tu deviens trop
qu'ils ont trois ans
s'ils passent au vote
le principe est très simple vous ouvrez
ce est bien là mais tu es sur le ballon
jeter le ballon rejeter le ballon et
vous l'a rattrapé en live ici
alors alors alors là le poteau elle est
à consommer avec modération mais c'est
du panache et ouais c'est qu'ils
modération j'aimerais bien le connaître
pour boire sans arrêt et buvez 15
millions d'abonnés
alors tu jettes la balle par terre avec
la bière dessus quand la balle va
toucher le sol la bière va partir dans
une direction d'un souffle au bond de la
balle tu dois alors l'attraper en plein
vol et boire une gorgée tu commences à
la famille c'est un prof la fin de la
vidéo
c'est le meilleur scénario s'est passé
début moi je d'aller bourrer le mou
on y parle m'ont vu sur tik tok soulage
son raid les parties mais peut-on même
pas fait défaut alors il ya une mère qui
a failli être si on rate ou les deux et
que rafa réussie vous m'acheter une île
j'ose pas les gars
[Musique]
c'est pour ça bonjour et essayer j'adore
déjà regardé bien 15 millions de
bouteilles regardez bien le trépied et
attention petit mouvement même si elle
est peu qu'on fait ça reste très dur il
l'a fait d'une manière extraordinaire
il faut le jouer mais je voudrais comme
une deuxième chute en voyant les gens
faire sur twitter je me disais mais ils
sont stupides c'est bête mais c'est
génial ce oui oui c'est vraiment j'ai
dit tu fais un endroit totalement raf
armand c'est à toi t'as essayé fait mais
je vais en dernier pour clore ce
chapitre
à
la la la la qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'ils
allaient me cas on est là bazire il a
espéré
ok les gars on est bon avec ça avec ce
premier truc très bien on fait la
pastèque pour te faire la peau steak le
fameux et c'est parti pour la pastèque
messieurs dames au la fameuse saillie
d'assassins les gars j'ai vu passer ou
dans une vidéo il ya pas longtemps que
j'ai fait sur ma chaîne youtube
donc c'est très simple on a une
plastique le but c'est très simple il
faut mettre élastique autour de la
pastèque et au bout d'un moment ça va la
faire exploser des malades on a des
élastiques un peu large et des traits
fins est-ce que les fins déjà parce
regarder passer complètement ça me fait
peur ça ça quand ça claque ça fonctionne
pas comme ça des gens déjà il faut bien
qu'on soit synchro que ce soit ça appuie
bien au même endroit toiture milieu
qu'on a et j'ai jamais vu un gars aussi
investi à attendre mais plusieurs bons
coups depuis 1 sur la butte ce qu'elle
fait
oui mais ma mère sa réponse les makes
retenez bien cette phrase s'offrir du
temps c'est super ça fait pas mal si ça
explose non non non
ce à quoi jean pull
j'ai trouvé la technique mais tu
trouveras qu'on dirait une tortue ninja
kids times ah ouais
pour moi on est juste en train de mettre
des élastiques autour d'une faste est
créée mais au bout d'un moment on n'en
pas douter sûr mais par contre ça ça
peut être terrible ce qui se passe la
connerie à d'autres l état s se déforme
se déforme vous avez vérifié les risques
les causes et conséquences de cela de ce
cher oui je vais vous donner du courage
pour éviter jusqu'à c'est le visage je
ramène un petit accessoire était en
train de me dire le cas que ça ça la
regarde et un becquet train de me dire
que ça ça va protéger mais oui c'est
fastoche qu'elle est beaucoup plus
vertical car en écoute par contre et des
mois pour sa lé gars j'ai l'impression
qu'on va mourir dans cette pièce et oui
mais un feeling c'est leur maman ça être
s'approche mais ça c'est l'art est ce
qu'ils pensent que tu vas me dire ne
faites pas ça chez vous sous aucun
prétexte
les gars c'est à moi d'en mettre un
on est en équipe on est en équipe
procédé qu'est-ce qu'ils ont juste eu
cet opus de merde
roland tis cap s'équipera puissant ce
que j'ai mis la regarde moi qui avais
peur de les traces de la terre rien
avait plus de pression dans une vie que
de faire ça je vous jure c'est vrai j'ai
l'impression de désamorcer une bombe à
désamorcer une base et regarde je fais
un énorme comme les élastiques je suis
le plus gros show le plus gros chez vous
la suite jean louis entrent au mont apic
applaudissements à lucas c'est lui qui a
eu le fin mot de l'histoire mais tu as
raison ça marche
abonnez-vous à la chaîne lucas on
t'écoute les gars là c'est un truc qu'on
voulait faire on va pas faire un vecteur
parce que possiblement ça peut retourner
sur quelqu'un et la société ne fait pas
ça en extérieur évidemment ne le fait
pas en extérieur ne le fait pas tout
court le but du rocket coca c'est de
réussir à fermer la bouteille secoué il
ya des mentos dedans et ensuite tu
l'envoies comme ça et si elle tombe sur
le bouchon elle va être projeté en fait
david est le spécialiste de cette
épreuve il la connaît très bien notre
écoute on a vite il faut qu'on arrive à
mettre des mentos dans une bouteille de
coca donc youtube de 2001 mais il faut
qu'on arrive ensuite a fermé la
bouteille il ya plusieurs techniques il
ya une technique qui consiste à coller à
l'intérieur de la bouteille avec du
scotch des petits manteaux s'est ensuite
secoué la bouteille j'y crois pas moi
j'ai envie de jouer la deuxième
technique et un peu plus risqué on va
devoir essayer de les mettre et de
cerner la bouteille rapidement ça serait
la bonne idée on est d'accord
combien on en met dedans il en faut
aussi ce que tu me regarde je crois
qu'on devrait faire des objets japonais
bon moi je propose de tester déjà avec
trois quatre cinq six ans non mais c'est
comme ça on est sur huit jeux mais les
motos et une fois que les emmy toi tu
fermes au plus vite la bouteille mais je
vais pas laisser la bouteille petit ami
si c'est pas les plus rien se passer je
pense pas que ça puisse exploser je suis
pas sûr de ce que j'avance je l'aimé et
tu fermes au plus vite
faire non plus vite quand y'en a qui
sont tombés 1 2 3 ok je suis chaud pour
faire mais attends mec ya genre une
fenêtre de quatre dixièmes de seconde
j'essaie comment améliorer
oui la vie d un peu de gaz cas de danse
et un peu de coke à kladno tout est
prétexte à boire et à manger chute avec
ça ça te remplir
j'ai mangé un mentos merde
non mais c'est l'erreur laisser jean
l'erreur d'internet dans mes mecs mais
ça va pour l'instant qu'aux voisins
[ __ ] mais quelle chacal 2 3 avec
inquiétons bien d'attaquer cette fois
c'est que ces quads avec talent les
garrigues à l'égal du progrès de malades
mais oublie stations jeunes on pas
plutôt technique manon azem laisser
faire ça arrive
ok 2 1 après 5 est prêt j'en fais un
deuxième jeu met les deux ça marche on
savait toujours dit que c'est
techniquement ça va secouer
c'était bien cette technique on refait
ça on analyse alexis revient fort ça
tombe bien c'est faux c'est quand tu
annonces elle tombe sur le bouchon elle
va partir et je jette sur le bouchon
voilà je tape mais la chose de côté
[Applaudissements]
parce que même là c'est audacieuse que
tu fais moi que je viens de le faire je
peux le refaire au queyran et la
montagne la toile joué à montferrand a
laissé entre tes mains ça cool so foot
le couple n'aurait raté les hydrater et
il a raté mais on peut leur est là en
plein fait rayonner vaziani 17 mars est
trop tard les gars
il est temps de passer au challenge
ultime les mecs suis là j'ai hâte de le
faire comment ça va t'en va t'en veux
vous serrer les mains les conditions
hygiéniques sont respectés là on joue et
on coville s'écoule alors les gars là
c'est un truc incroyable que je veux
faire depuis très longtemps aussitôt
j'ai vu passer aussi tout je me suis dit
je vais le faire c'est le forum
challenge ça s'appelle en gros c'est une
réaction chimique qui entraînent une
création de mousse démentiel ok tant les
ingrédients il ya un truc très corrosif
pour la pause qui explique nos tenues
évidemment ne faites pas ça chez vous
sous aucun prétexte
on va commencer avec un tout petit
dosage est ce que je vais dire les
ingrédients pour que les gens puissent
leur faire chez eux
bien sûr que non les mecs sur m'angoisse
mais jamais on peut s'en sortir par an
premier ok ok ok inquiète mais pas grand
chose on dégage c'est pas grave c'est
une petite c'est pas grave c'est un
essai est un essai ça va pas exposés là
on en voit en en venant vous en envoie
en envoyant d'envoi on en voit encore
encore encore encore encore encore
encore encore sa psychologie rouge
on y va sur 11 des familles une petite
housse voilà point trop n'en faut voilà
messieurs dames à temps vas-y à celle
employée le vert il a exposé on va
mourir
non on enlevait elle explose par
pression qu'on est dans un tpe fait
partie phase iib ben si tu regardes dos
à un prix de la mousse
on marche pendant la donne n'est pas là
c'est bien ça rigole pas là
ok deuxième best seller en battant les
gallois faire vas-y
les gars vous êtes renseigné sur comment
vous appelez le regarder
[Musique]
on n'abandonne pas des gars c'est plus
joli c'est pas un truc de l'asacar
ballon de basket la quatrième essai pour
la changeait pas grand chose en espérant
un résultat différent c'est la
définition de la folie
[Musique]
attends c'est un succès ou un échec j'ai
pas compris c'est un succès total
peut on a changé un des ingrédients mais
qui n'est je pense que c'est pas le bon
truc je suis quasi sûr georges par nîmes
à ce repas c'est pareil
exactement comme la ici on va faire un
look et olten non regard du genji galère
pas si vous les gars ça ne peut pas
marcher toutes les vidéos qu'on a
regardé ses des formules chimiques très
brésil
nous on a vraiment fait on est très vite
dans cette vidéo on est parti on aura
tout essayé
regardez ce qui se passe les amis il est
fatigué parce qu'il a organisé ça et
c'est dur la défaite surtout pour un mec
qui veut qu'ils n'échouent pas on échoue
on revient dans quelques jours ont fait
passer le week-end à l'est pour lui dis
juste ok il y avait un problème d'un
gradient mais c'est un problème qui est
apparemment désormais régler moi moi je
fais quoi
si ce n est les meilleurs imaginez
imaginez un seul instant que savard
salle où je tombe malade jetons et je
suis pas sûr de relever parce que tu
l'auras bien dit il ya un week-end qui
s'est écoulé entre l'ajax et lundi matin
il vient d'arriver
attendez je rajoute un petit ingrédient
après la file historique trois jours
d'essais d'une équipe au taquet on est
reparti s'ils ne se passe rien
c'est un grand moment 3 2 or
ça a marché assez joli assez fou on
dirait une salle bonnafous mais c'est
beau alors attendez c'est un nouveau
sentiment qui vient de se passer sur la
chaîne de lucas à la fois un peu content
et à la fois déçus qui est content si on
est tous contents c'est bon les gars
c'est c'est donc un peu décevant ce
qu'on devait faire maintenant c'est
essayer dans un truc bien trop gros à là
on se parle effectivement à tfo toi
aussi one stop stop c'est j'ai jamais vu
ça dans aucune vidéo konami
j'ai peur d'être content su animer recul
aride 2,3 au contentieux comptant sur je
vous dis on fait un dernier baiser n'ont
jamais non plus
écoutez bien cette phrase d'un grand
chimiste on veut tous plus olivier sais
quoi mais tous mes voisines ont mais
c'est bon mais tout cela mais tu diouf
c'est la fin de notre vie en même temps
les amis c'est le dernier essai de cette
vidéo haute en couleur dont la moralité
est toujours plus est en étant nul
attention si c'est facile si tu vois
plus de mousse plus de densité dans les
gares
nous sommes désormais dans tous les
livres de physique chimie de la sixième
à la terminale
regardez ça c'est mon état intérieur là
rené devant la caméra parce que j'ai pu
j'ai un truc à vous proposer
on referme épisode 2 on se concentre lui
sur la mousse que cette fois ci on
remplit vraiment genre un truc très long
avec quelqu'un qui dit mais non c'est ça
un chimiste quoi avec un chimiste et la
vidéo elle s'appellera on a pris notre
revanche
oui enfin grâce entre parenthèses grâce
à un professeur renommé matière en tout
cas la physique-chimie ce n'est pas ça
aux lois de la physique chimie si vous
ne savez pas faire de la physique si
vous ne faites rien de tout ça chez vous
merci à vous de rassurer cette vidéo
malgré nos échecs malgré
[Musique]